おはようございます
朝8時
はじめしゃちょーです
青森からワニブン君というYouTuberの子が遊びに来てるんですけども
昨日、飲んで飲んで寝ております
ぐっすり
今まで数々の寝起きドッキリ、目覚ましをしてきたんですけども
今回はこちら
ブブゼラを使おうと思ってます
これすげーちゃっちいように見えて
めちゃくちゃ音が大きくて
問題にもなったくらいらしいです
1mほど長さのあるラッパの一種で
スタジアムホーンとも呼ばれるチアホーンの一種です
唇に当てて吹くだけで
象の鳴き声のような単調な、しかし非常に大きな音が出ると
ブブゼラは127㏈
の音を出すことから耳栓の使用が推奨されてるくらい
耳栓付けなきゃダメなんだね
で、イベント中にも音がデカすぎて
使用が禁止になる例とかもあるくらい
ちゃっちく見えて
多分今までよりかなり危険な
いや、かなり目覚まし的には良い感じだと思います
事前調査によりますと
ワニブン君は寝起きドッキリされても起きるタイプじゃないらしいです
でっかい音出してもパッと起きない
そこらへんをねこのブブゼラ君で
突破できればと思っております
あ、やばいやばい、本当にやばい本当にデカいぞ
あ～もう本当にやばいわ
僕流の朝の挨拶を
ワニブン君に教えようと思います
ではいこう
ワニブン：え？
はじめ：え、すご
はじめ：全然反応しないじゃん
寝起き
ワニブン：え？
ワニブン：あ、ああーー
（笑）
友達：うるさーい
友達：ううーーううーーー